last year kadhal was the center of a
tois reg uprising against the mollies
government a french-led military
intervention brought the region under
government control but pockets of
insurgency remain jeslin do Paul and
Claude verlon traveled to the
northeastern town to interview a local
official from at Warwick separatist
group for video France Internationale
the official told French media that
after their meeting he heard a commotion
outside his house and saw the
journalists being bundled into a
four-wheel drive it's the last time they
were seen alive two hours later their
bodies were found riddled with bullets
alongside the abandoned vehicle after an
emergency meeting called by the
president in Paris France's foreign
minister blamed terrorists and said
French troops would boost security in
the region see that came quarterly
pepsin it's a crime against two people
were assassinated in cold blood under
inhuman conditions would use but it's
also a crime against the basic freedom
to inform go and to be a warranty that
for me it did that for me the head of
the RFI condemned the killings but
declared the network will not be
intimidated secession Ababa what can we
do in the face of such barbarity should
we stop going to certain places stop
providing information the answer is no
surer than normal do Paul and Val own
were veteran Africa correspondence they
were in kadhal earlier this year to
cover the first round of the
presidential election